alors oui j'ai envoyé des notes vocales
en disant des choses compromettantes sur
il a oui oui des messages vous dit né
d'un gris souris lan ou aussi j'ai
montré des vidéos il ya des ébats
sexuelles dit l'acte empreinte de
s'amuser avec des basses et ses plans
cul en train de s'amuser avec des filles
qui sont bien évidemment majeur d'accord
qui montrait des vidéos mais ce n'est
pas des vidéos où ils violent défi
d'accord donc arrêtez ces vidéos seront
donnés à la justice
oui irons au tribunal et prouveront que
ilan est innocent ah ouais bien mais moi
ça me gêne un peu sur la fin mais
j'adore cbi a dit je trouve très drôle
franchement il fait des vidéos très
drôle mais là en fait on sait pas s'ils
jouent la comédie ou pas fois qu'il
s'exprime pas calmement posément il
parle quand même d'un sujet grave donc
on sait pas du tout senti d'abord comme
ça tout le temps comme ça mais avoir
besoin de regarder donc non mais il est
il est sincère le sérieux et sincère là
dessus mais c'est sérieux là dessus il
reste que pour le moment cette vidéo
dans mon esprit - elle n'existe pas face
à dire que lui dément aqua babe qu'on a
vu avec guillaume qui est très proche
il n'y a aucune vidéo avec une agression
sexuelle donc ça ça comment cela allait
dans le sens dylan d'accord est à dire
qu il ya des vidéos d'ébats sexuels
c'est vrai c'est ce qu' aucune agression
que nous avons pu authentifiant alors au
gala on a une vidéo d'une agression et
dylan regarder je sais pas s'il faut la
prendre au sérieux c'est à gaz où vous
l'avez vous pas non regardez
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
albon jours et alors c'est quoi si tu es
une vague non il ya quelques jours il n
il a tourné cette vidéo pour
sensibiliser les gens aux cyber
harcèlement à bien des coûts qui ressort
cette vidéo elle devait jamais sortir
parce que c'est un peu raté on va pas se
mentir il ya quelqu'un qui l'a sorti en
tout cas en aucun cas il a voulu faire
croire d'accord mais c'est suis très
bien voilà ok très bien merci guillaume
parce que je suis
moi j'appelle ça me gêne un peu cette
histoire parce qu'on parle quand même
d'une agression sur mineure alors je
sais pas si c'est l'europe
résumé jeudi en rigoles là d'une fausse
agression ils sont tous les deux en
train de se battre en faisant plein
c'est vrai le téléphone sonne pour
l'instant il est vidéo n'existe pas
quand on aura la vidéo mais sérieusement
mais pourquoi avec seraient accusés
quand on aime beaucoup à l'igf est pour
l'instant la vidéo on la part donc que
quand on aura la vidéo pour en créer
d'autres disent qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
des pressions et que c'est pour ça que
cette vidéo n'existe pas ne resurgit
parler à côté moi je vous dis une vidéo
une vidéo énormément elle sortir à un
moment ça c'est sûr et certain et on
voit attendons moi j'ai une vidéo in the
belly mme
non mais c'est vrai voilà avec des
tupperware
ça sortira un moment